Tiangong 1 ist abgestürzt der abschlag wie zuvor vermutet in unbewohntem gebiet, im pazifik doch
im erdorbit lauer noch ganz andere risiken die weitaus
Gefährlicher sind wieder absturz ablief ob es gefährlich hätte werden können und wo die großen gefahren durch
Weltraumschrott drohen jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja das war das etwas unrühmliche ende der ersten chinesischen raumstation
vollkommen unkontrolliert stürzte sie auf die erde mit dem risiko menschen zu verletzen und größeren schaden anzurichten um 2 uhr 15
Stürzte die unbemannte raumstation in der nähe von tahiti in den pazifik vorab hatte die chinesische
raumfahrtbehörde noch mitgeteilt dass tiangong 1 vor der brasilianischen
millionenmetropole sao paulo in den atlantik stürzen würde also
immerhin nahe einer millionenstadt also nicht ganz ungefährlich dabei
Verfehlte sie point nemo also jetzt im pazifik an ihrem absturz ort den dortigen friedhof für raumschiffe
raumstationen und satelliten nur knapp dort werden ausgediente raum fahrzeuge kontrolliert zum absturz gebracht die stelle ist jeweils rund
2600 kilometer vom nächsten stück land entfernt und das ist wirklich ein riesiger
abstand wenn man sich vorstellt dass die raumstation iss in rund 400 kilometern
Höhe um die erde kreist deswegen ist point nemo übrigens auch als pazifischer pohl der
Unzulänglichkeit bekannt etwa zwei wochen braucht man um dorthin mit dem schiff zu kommen und natürlich auch wieder zwei wochen um zurück
Zu gelangen das risiko dass ein trümmerteil auf land einschlägt dass gezielt support nemo gesteuert wurde ist also
nahezu null die gefahr dass hier irgendjemand geschädigt wird absolut minimal point nemo wurde übrigens mit hilfe eines computerprogramms
Entdeckt und zwar im jahr 1992 von dem kroatischen
Vermessungstechniker rivoli luca tel den namen hat dieser ort allerdings nicht vom fisch nemo aus dem zeichentrickfilm
sondern verdankt in einer romanfiguren zwar captain nemo aus
20.000 meilen unter dem meer von jules verne an dieser stelle
Im ozean vermutet man nur wenig leben denn der wind kann nur wenige nährstoffen tragen
Da das nächste land so weit entfernt liegt starke meeresströmung
halten
nährstoffreiches wasser
Außerdem ab also wirklich der ideale ort um alles zu begraben was man nicht mehr braucht laut nasa ist dies vor allem für größere objekte
Eben wir aus stationen und raumfahrzeuge die sich in einer niedrigen umlaufbahn befinden eine gute möglichkeit
denn
Bei
ihnen besteht die gefahr dass sie eben nicht vollständig verbrennen bevor sie den erdboden erreichen solche raumschiffe und
satelliten werden dann kontrolliert, am point nemo zum absturz gebracht es gibt schätzungen nach denen hier mehr als
260 raumfahrzeuge
Beerdigt worden sind und die zahl ist in den letzten jahren gewaltig gestiegen unter anderem ich sehe auch die
142 tonnen schwere raumstation die russische raumstation mir 'nen begraben eigentlich sollen dort alle
raumfahrzeuge landen die nicht mehr genutzt werden aber bei den rang eines haben die chinesen 2016 die kontrolle verloren ist bliebe nichts anderes übrig als
dem absturz zuzusehen für die
raumfahrtagenturen weltweit war es damit aber die gelegenheit ein objekt über so lange zeit
Zu verfolgen und ihre tracking systeme zu schicken beim absturz ist die raumstation laut chinesischer raumfahrtbehörde cms
Größtenteils verglüht so dass nur noch wenige teile dort abgestürzt sind vorab wurde geschätzt dass es teile mit einem gesamtgewicht von
1,5 bis 3,5 tonnen sein würden dabei ist der absturz eines satelliten oder raumschiffes eigentlich etwas
positives denn dann kann es oben
Im erd orbit keinen schaden mehr anrichten denn die unzähligen anderen trümmerteile die den weltraum mittlerweile regelrecht vermüllen stellen eine bedrohung für uns da
sagen forschungsteams weltweit die nasa warnt vor einer unkontrollierbaren
kettenreaktion eine absolute katastrophe dass kessler syndrom
ausgelöst durch einen crash werden innerhalb von stunden ein großteil der flugkörper rund um die erde zerstören inklusive der internationalen raumstation iss
immer wieder schlittern wir knapp daran vorbei es gab bereits 200 kollisionen von satelliten
Im orbit der erde die ihnen nicht auf die erde gestürzt sind und jede produziert wieder neue schrott teilchen inzwischen geht man von achtung
166 millionen trümmerteilen aus die um die erde schwören wir sind im moment quasi zeuge eines kessler sind roms in zeitlupe
spektakulärer höhepunkt 2009 stoßen der iridium satelliten
33 das iridium satelliten
telefonnetzes gewicht eine halbe tonne und der russische satellit cosmos 2251 zusammen bei einer aufprallgeschwindigkeit
und von
40.000 kilometern pro stunde bleibt von den beiden satelliten mehr übrig außer
100.000 schrottteilen sie haben jetzt die chancen für den nächsten unfall deutlich erhöhen wir können also
Happy sein das sie morgens auf die erde gestürzt ist und dort oben keinen schaden anrichten kann der wäre im zweifel nämlich größer als hier
Auf der erde wenn ihr als erstes neues zum thema
weltraumschrott und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer hier bei whatsapp
Dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantiert und zur begrüßung gibt es noch ein kleines
Goodie, es lohnt sich also also hier einfach draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken 1000 raketen zum mars ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran